*chanté* L'Histoooire...
Racontée paaar...
Des chausseeettes...
C'est très marrant.
Salut m'sieur Lucas !
Alors ? Comment ça se passe mon casting, hein ?
Ça se passe bien ?
Tu trouves des bons acteurs pour mon film ?
J'veux des nains dans des robots, t'oublies pas.
Des nains dans des robots.
Ouais... Mais c'est pas évident, hein.
Les acteurs comprennent pas tout vu que ça se passe dans l'espace...
Les personnages c'est des extraterrestres...
Très bien, très bien, c'est bien.
Et tu me fais un beau casting, hein !
*chanté* J'vais faire un film dans l'espace !
J'vais faire un film dans l'espace !
Et dans vingt ans j'vais tout massacrer avec des images de synthèse ! Ouais !
Casting Chewbacca candidat 73.
Bonjour.
Enchanté !
Présentez-vous.
Je m'appelle Trevor Bottleneg et je suis comédien anglais de formation classique théâtrale.
Je peux vous réciter un poème de Lord Byron
Ou jouer la mort de Roméo avec le foulard rouge pour faire le sang.
Non, ça va je crois.
Heu... Vous connaissez votre texte ?
Ah, alors, justement, il doit y avoir l'erreur, je n'ai reçu que des voyelles.
Non, oui, c'est ça.
C'est des cris, en fait.
C'est...Mais...
Où est la profondeur du personnage ?
Ça je sais pas, c'est des cris en fait.
Mais, pourquoi il crie ?
Il a mal ?
La voiture marche pas ?
Les prix sont trop chers ?
Tu vois le Yéti ?
Oui.
Il crie.
Hé ben Chewbacca...
Oui.
Il crie.
Oh.
Voilà
Mais comment voulez-vous, par exemple, faire passer une émotion sous-jacente
Si la situation devient trop insoutenable et que la catharsis est "over the top" ?
Vous voulez bien faire les cris qu'y a écrit sur la feuille ?
Non monsieur.
Non, Trevor Bottleneg ne crie pas.
Il vit.
Vous connaissez la devise de Shakespeare ?
Non.
"D'abord des mots, ensuite des mots, et enfin des mots."
Vous êtes sûr ?
C'est pas "si on y va à quatre ça va aller plus vite" ?
Non.
Non ?
OK.
Fais les cris ?
Pfff...
Au revoir, monsieur.
Bon, là on est vraiment dans une impasse, hein.
Excusez-moi !
Alors, j'v...
Ah oui oui, non mais je croyais qu'il n'y en avait plus du tout, donc venez, c'est très bien. Entrez. Présentez-vous.
Heeuuu...
Bah j'm'appelle Peter Meyou...
Et... Je suis infirmier.
Ouais, c'est parti pour les cris.
Pardon ?
Les cris !
Nan, nan mais moi, en fait, je travaille juste dans l'immeuble
Et j'venais vous dire...
CRIE !
Mais... Quelle sorte de cris ?
Un cri d'extraterrestre humanoïde à fourrure de la race des Wookies qui serait une sorte de croisement entre un ours un lion et un labrador j'en ai marre d'être ici...
CRIE !
*cris*
Voilà.
Voilà !
*cris*
Parfait ! Je t'engage, et je démissionne.
Et c'est ainsi que Chewbacca est devenu un personnage emblématique de Star Wars.
Avant que Jar Jar Binks ne viennent tout détruire.
En tout cas d'après les chaussettes.
*cris*